if you're up for more space and more
shooting then ea's recently announced
release windows for some of that coming
games will make you very happy indeed
I'm Kate and this is your gamespot news
update EA had previously stated that
titanfall 2 or whatever it ends up being
called the new battlefield and Mass
Effect Andromeda would be out during
fiscal year twenty 17 which runs from
april first 2016 through march 31st 2017
not that there was any reason to believe
they would be out prior to this fall but
CFO blake jorgensen confirmed during a
conference call with investors that
they're all slated for launch during the
second half of the fiscal year that
translates to somewhere between october
2016 and march 2017 you should assume
that a battlefield will come typically
in the third quarter when we normally
have it he said we're not yet announcing
when titanfall or Mass Effect Andromeda
will come but you should assume that
it's in the back half of the year as
well because the second quarter
july-to-september is so dominated by our
sports titles little is known about any
of the three games EA CEO Andrew Wilson
said during the same call that the new
titanfall is looking fantastic meanwhile
Bioware recently offered the free fist
of teases about Andromeda and the next
battlefield returns to the military
style sounds pretty good right let me
know what you think in the comments will
come and find me on Twitter I'm at how
not to draw thanks for watching and for
all your gaming and entertainment news
keep it gamespot